[Music]
now listen here you buffoon if you
scuttle any more of my luggage i will
gosh there's a lot of you isn't there
yeah there is lily
really
not without my sister come on get your
stuff let's go
[Music]
toiletries
why are they chasing us i have no idea
here's the english woman
[Music]
what i don't know what that means
[Music]
follow me don't go up there it's that
way
lady it's that way
[Music]
baby leave the monkeys the monkeys are
fine
don't go out there
[Music]
ladies stop not frank
how you doing pants yeah i was trying to
tell you about the end
up come on
come on lady jump what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
of course she is
[Music]
come on lady
oh god sorry frank sorry strong form
my name is dr lily houghton my brother
and i are looking for passage upriver
what's out there in the jungle it's not
a fun vacation well i'm not here for a
vacation
legend has it that there is a tree that
possesses unparalleled healing power
it will change medicine forever and you
need someone to help you find it here we
go sometimes it just needs a bit of a
nobody touches my engine but me what did
i just
there you go
she was always chasing after some
far-fetched idea
[Music]
do you want to turn back nope just
getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
torpedo oh my
[Music]
you